but you know at the end of the day it's
like
I I see where they're coming from I
don't hate them they're prioritizing
their job which is maximize profits and
they're not looking after me that's not
their job I don't expect them to so the
writers have to look after ourselves and
at the end of the day we want we want
the same thing that they want which is
they want to make boatloads of money and
we want to be the people who make them
that boatloads of money right that's it
we just want to be able to afford to be
able to do that
thank you
[Music]
it's a pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast someone who's going to make
sense of the wga strike and all the
things that are going on in Hollywood or
not going on screenwriter show runner
Michael Jamin is with us Michael welcome
thank you so much for having me what an
honor oh the honor is all mine uh
especially because you were the creative
force behind King of the Hill Beavis and
Butthead I want to say Marin some Middle
High comedy I'm a huge Mike Judge fan
yeah he's great yeah I don't know about
creative Force I was one of the writers
in some of those shows but uh I think
that qualifies okay so more recently
you've been and putting out various
messages about something that a lot of
people want demystified which is this
wga strike uh and appreciate the words
of wisdom
um a great deal what's like a snapshot
of the message you're trying to get out
there well okay so okay I don't know if
there's a snapshot but basically the the
TV writing landscape has changed so much
of the past I don't say 10 or 15 years
with streaming so the the uh Studios
have changed their business model uh
which is how they want to present TV
shows but they haven't changed the way
writers have gotten paid and so the
result is that writers are making four
percent less uh than we did 10 years ago
but adjusted for inflation it's actually
23 percent less and during that same
amount of time the studios their profits
have gone up by 39 but adjusted for
inflation it's up 195 wow so it's really
just about being our compensation
basically hasn't kept up well you're a
man after my own heart because you had
the numbers at your fingertips uh yeah
and let me say that I'm sympathetic
um because I wanted to be a writer when
I was young I went to law school which
is what a lot of wannabe Writers Do yeah
I know yeah oh I'm sure you have friends
who resemble that yes um but the the
folks who do manage to write for a
living uh I I think people probably
overestimate uh both the money and the
job security that goes into that because
they're they're there uh oftentimes for
the love uh they're genuine creators uh
and I've talked to several of them
who've had a harder and harder time
making a full-time living at writing
even people who have very very lofty
credits to their name shall we say yeah
like people where you're like oh if you
did that you must be made in the shade
and then they are not made in the shade
and some of them are having to
supplement their their writing job with
other work yes for sure uh you know I've
been it gets harder and harder to make
to make a living
um yeah I mean you're exactly right it's
uh it's it's not most writers are middle
class they're not super rich you people
have heard of a handful that are really
rich but most of us are not and most of
us you know there's no job security
which is okay we we go into the business
knowing that uh most people who feel you
know Chase creative Fields they're like
all right they're willing to sacrifice
uh the steady paycheck for the for the
love of the living a creative life but
um no we mostly we we're always we have
one job we're always searching for the
next job in some ways it was easier when
I first broke in this is a long time ago
my first job was on just shoot me and so
if you're on a hit show you would work
uh let's say 10 months out of the year
and most writers get paid per episode
produced so you do let's say 22 Episodes
a season that's a good year and then you
take a short Hiatus and you go back for
the next season that's if you're on a
hit show but now with streaming if
you're on a hit show you might do eight
episodes in a season
and how do you make less than 22. yeah
it's a lot less and then making it worse
is the way these Studios uh are paying
you so that in the old days you'd be uh
assigned on the show for the whole
duration of the show to help produce the
show but now they only have you for
pre-production so maybe for many shows
rather uh so maybe you're only working
let's say two or three months out of the
year so p
think of this as the streaming strike
which you just described it as
um one element of negotiations is
something called a mini room what the
heck is a mini room it can mean a lot of
different things but basically in the
past a studio uh or a network they they
you write a writer would sell a pilot
they write their pilot script the studio
or the network they would read the
script they say okay we like the script
we'll shoot the pilot if we like what we
shoot then maybe we'll put it on the air
everything's a long shot but that's the
of the steps and you get paid along each
step but now the Studios have realized
you know they were they weren't
comfortable absorbing that much risk
maybe there's a way we could pass that
risk on to the writers themselves and so
now uh it's not uncommon for a writer to
sell a pilot script to to a network and
the network says okay we like it but
we're not sure if we want to go forward
with this so instead We'll order two or
three more scripts from you we'll give
you a small budget to hire a writing
staff but but only two or three writers
and we're not going to let you they're
not going to get paid full we're only
going to pay them a fraction of their
rate because we don't know if we're
actually going to put this on the air so
therefore you should get a discount but
that's kind of like walking in
it requires a writer the same amount of
work to write an episode of Television
whether you put it on the air or not
it's the same amount of work and so it's
kind of like walking into a deli and
saying how much for that turkey sandwich
oh it's ten dollars okay well how much
for that turkey sandwich if I don't eat
it
it's still ten dollars I don't care what
you're going to do with it it's but
you're gonna throw it out Michael yeah
well that's uh that's your decision to
throw up yeah and and sometimes then
they'll be like oh cool we have these
cheaper scripts uh that we paid less
money for and let's use them and and if
you're a writer it's hard to turn it
down because you're like well it's
a paying job and you know it's a lower
rate than normal but at least I'll get
paid that month or two months or
whatever yes right it's it's that or
unemployment so there there's the wga
which has already gone on strike and uh
people have probably seen people
um protesting in in various ways and
then the uh sag-aftra uh Union voted to
authorize a strike uh and then that
could kick in a little bit later on can
you help people understand the
distinction yeah so it's the same thing
with the writer's Guild first when when
negotiations are don't aren't going that
well and it doesn't seem like there's
going to go that well the guild sends
out a met uh like we need to strike
authorization vote which means are you
behind us it's sends a strong message to
to who you're negotiating against saying
uh The Guild is like it was something
like 98 of the guild said okay we author
we are we authorize a strike we're not
saying we're going on strike but we're
saying here's the threat is very real if
you need to go if the guild membership
says we need to go on strike we're ready
and so 98 of the guild said yes you have
our blessing to go on strike if need be
and negotiations broke down the bill
said that's it we're on strike now so a
high turnout and a high uh like that 98
is really hard to get that's like 90.
you can't get people to agree that the
sun rises you know in the East uh yeah
so this is I'm just kidding
yeah I mean you're basically saying
yeah we agree to this it's very hard and
so it was a strong turnout and very
strong it sends a strong message if it
was only like 68 that would be like the
the uh the producers would know okay
they're not United on this
foreign
I am pumped to announce that I have a
novel coming out on September 12th the
last election it's a political thriller
co-written with my friend Stephen Marsh
who wrote the book the next civil war if
you listen to this podcast Steven's been
a repeat guest even and I became friends
and thought we should collaborate on a
way to scare the out of people but
also entertain them with a story of what
could happen in this upcoming election
or the election thereafter do check it
out at andrewyang.com books and there's
a special discount code last election
that you can use for 30 off at the
Publisher's website I'll be talking more
about this book but I'm so pumped to get
this out into the world last election
coming your way
so there's this element of the fact that
look streaming came along completely
changed the production schedules the
number of episodes uh comp didn't keep
up
um and I think of this as the streaming
strike if you were to be very uh you
know simplistic about it but it's also
somehow become the AI strike uh where
Apparently one of the earlier sticking
points and negotiations was writers
saying look you can't use AI to generate
scripts and then the studios are like
hard pass on that like we totally want
to be able to use it yeah
and and you have some opinions as to
what AI can and can't do well yeah so
the writer skill just wants to regulate
it and I'm not on the guild negotiating
committee so I'm not exactly sure what
they're asking for but the studios like
you're saying it's hard pass that's off
the table we're not going to let you now
ai currently can't write anything close
to being usable uh the quality that
we're writing currently uh but the
studios are at least optimistic that in
the near future it might be good enough
and good enough is good enough and so
and you know how yeah it works it's just
a plagiarism tool that scrapes the
internet for other stuff that we've
written and amalgamates it and and
hopefully uh we'll make something good
up so no writer in their right mind it's
like signing your own death wish no
writer is going to agree to a contract
that says okay yeah sure phase me out
I'll sign right here phase me out you
know I mean I I people probably know
I've been concerned about the impact of
AI for quite some time this is an early
navigation of uh how AI is going to be
used because if you're a studio you're
like I want to be able to use this thing
yeah if you're the writers you're like
well like I'm not gonna freaking help
automate my myself out of a job I mean
you know like I have to do this for
years to come oh when I did run for
president I ran on this notion that AI
is going to eat a lot of jobs and we
should start giving everyone money uh
called it the freedom dividend set it at
a thousand bucks a month
um now that's not a whole lot in
Hollywood
um but do you think that something like
Ubi what it would help people transition
I mean it's sort of you know obviously
it's like something of a leading
question you know though and I think
about AI a lot right now and it's it's
so interesting it's like we've created
this God let's worship it uh this
artificial God you know the Arts no one
goes into the Arts hoping to become rich
like I said that's why you're Starving
Artists until you start making some
money and what the Arts allow us to do
is understand ourselves and help create
something and turn something inside of
us into something more positive and
hopefully understand ourselves and our
place in society and hope other people
do the same but AI will never be able to
write about The Human Experience because
it's not human and whatever it scrapes
from the internet comes from other
writers but it'll never be authentic
it'll only be artificial and so if you
really are interested in writing
something or watching something that
really moves you I think it has to come
from a human now I am interested to know
what this is until AI becomes sentient I
mean when then things change but then AI
will be able to write a story about what
it's like to be a computer and I'd be
interested in reading that story but
right now I can't do anything close to
that it's not sentient and I can't write
about The Human Experience because it's
not human
and so if if art moves you in any way
then I think you're going to need to put
a premium on human writers yeah this is
Humanity Against the Machine it's uh
like a story of the modern day economy
uh AI it's one reason why I I think this
strike is so important uh it's getting a
lot of coverage in the Press but I don't
even think it's getting enough honestly
uh who owns the media
the media companies not the writers
this reminds me a little bit of politics
Michael I'm not gonna lie yeah yeah I'm
sure it does yeah but but social media
helps with that though because that way
writers can tell our own stories on
social media and you can hear it from us
what it's like Well you certainly seem
like a human being Michael yeah you
certainly seem like uh like a relatable
professional and creative and people can
I'm sure see themselves uh in you one of
the reasons why I wanted to have you on
is that I think there is this
unfortunate tendency to uh have like a
preconception as to what it means to be
a Hollywood writer
um where folks imagine you to be you
know on top of the world
um and the rest of it whereas I I know
that not to be the case for the vast
majority of the the members of The Guild
yeah yeah so you one thing you also talk
about is like it takes a while to get
good uh at screenwriting you don't just
sort of come out of the box uh like what
was that that development process for
you
it's so you know so many people say I
have a script how do I sell my script
and like they don't ask the question how
do I become a writer like that's the
first thing you like how do you write
and learning how to tell a story that
takes so long even when I first broke in
I was good enough to get a job as a
staff writer but I certainly wasn't good
enough to know what I was doing it took
a long time it takes a lot of work to
figure out how to do this and it's just
a process of finally when you get to be
good enough when you get to be my age
then you're like all right we don't need
you anymore it's such a long process to
learn how to become a writer so one
thing people might not appreciate is how
much guidance and mentorship happens in
these writers rooms and a lot of your
posts you talk about how uh you were
uh the beneficiary of mentorship in
various ways and that having everyone on
strike actually is is damaging people in
ways that people might not understand
yeah so when you first start on a TV
show like my first staff job was just
shoot me and I was young and I was with
you're you're on a writing staff with a
bunch of experienced writers and a
handful of you know brand new writers
and the the exit the experience right
it's like blew my mind like how much
they knew how much it was like I I
couldn't even I was just in awe of them
and there's so much to learn from them
and it takes so much time to finally get
up to their level anywhere close to
their level and part of it then of
course is going on set and hearing how
the upper level writers or the show
winner uh talks to the director how they
interact with the actors how they make
uh the decisions to actually produce the
show which is a whole different thing
and the way it is now
that's that's like that's a mentorship
basically so but the way it is now new
writers often aren't even invited to
this set they're not on the show long
enough to be on set and it like I don't
know how they could ever possibly run
their own show when they don't know the
actual producing part of running of
creating a TV show there's so much to
learn and yeah that would be tough
um so it sounds like that pipeline of
experience is also something that's
changing because of the way these shows
are getting produced now yeah yeah many
new writers are not have never been on
set they could be on a show for three
years and they've never even been on set
they have no idea what goes on after the
words have been written on a page
yeah it would be impossible to run a
show yeah if you haven't been on set so
many new writers say that to me they say
I want to be a short winner like you
don't even know what the job is yet hang
on do you want to be a staff writer
first and then maybe maybe showrunner
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
what the heck is Helix sleep it is the
mattress of the future company I have
always been someone who valued my sleep
figured you know you're gonna do it for
seven maybe even eight hours you wake up
feeling refreshed and energized what is
that worth Helix sleep can help make
that happen just take their sleep quiz
and figure out what personalized
mattress should be shipped straight to
your door and you have a hundred days to
return it I don't recommend returning it
after 99 days but hey who am I to say
don't take my word for it it's the
number one rated mattress from GQ and
wired can you imagine being the mattress
tester it's a job someone has it Helix
is offering 20 off all mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
right now go to helixsleep.com
yang this is their best offer yet and it
won't last long with Helix better sleep
start it's now
[Music]
foreign
so people have already seen an impact a
bunch of shows have gone into repeats or
Hiatus there are various movies uh and
other TV shows that have stopped filming
um in in various ways and the sense of
things is that the Screen Actors Guild
is going to join the writers
in in this effort now as a an avid
consumer of content first let me say
that it seems like the main variable as
to whether I think something is good or
not is something I'm going to call good
writing like that no like if something's
badly written I just started I had to
turn on it you know I mean like watching
some screaming show and then they do
something that like strikes me as
unrealistic or out of character or just
you know like overly convenient and then
you just like you know you turn the
channel and then the the shows you do
like they have well-drawn characters uh
that you become invested in in various
ways so again you can tell I'm very
sympathetic
to the writer's cause so someone said
that the last writer strike it was
behind Trump's rise to power because uh
they ended up investing in reality TV
including the apprentice and then that's
how Trump wound up in everyone's living
room
to some degree I mean I know reality was
around before the writers trick I mean
to Survivor I don't remember when
Survivor first came on but it was a big
hit long before that writers strike but
yeah uh it certainly led to more reality
television because they got to put
something on the air and they decided to
put that on yeah um and so you'll
probably see some kind of adaptation
like that if this strike drags on and on
um I believe that writers strike 15
years ago lasted a hundred days yeah
something like three plus months yeah
um uh I have this fear that this one's
going to go longer
um uh because the issues seem somehow
stickier and more intractable or tougher
to navigate I will say that occasionally
I have imagined what I would do if I
were let's say president United States
or something like that and
and uh something crazy like that yeah
but uh I I actually think that it would
be in the National interest for someone
to try and mediate this thing
um and one of my great concerns about it
dragging on and on is that I think the
studios are going to say hey let's not
give on this AI thing let's just uh like
convert to reality programming uh and we
can Outlast the writers because some of
them don't have that much money they're
you know human beings with households
and bills to pay and whatnot
um I think the studios are going to
think that time is on their side uh and
and that's something that's very dark to
talk openly about but ordinarily you're
in a position where it's like look I'm
gonna deprive you and my ability to uh
get a good deal is going to increase
over time
um because you know like you you need us
and they do need writers for sure
um but on this one like I feel like the
studios might think like oh like you
know we we actually can wait this thing
out I I I would like there to be like a
real Earnest hard-headed negotiation
earlier rather than wait four or five
months uh maybe even longer
Unfortunately
um to try and hammer out a deal that
might look like something you could have
figured out uh earlier but that's just
you know me essentially imagining what I
would do if I Were Somehow uh in power
and have the ability well here's what I
think is different than the 2008 strike
uh first of all in 2008
you know the studios had this on their
side which was can you guys really
afford to be out of work for three
months or six months and then the
writer's like yeah I don't know right
but in 2023 most writers already are out
of work for two for three months or six
months that's what the strike is over so
what difference does it make if we go on
strike when we're already out of work it
doesn't change anything so that's the
first thing the second thing is yes the
2008 led to the rise of reality
television but but back then television
was consumed differently back then it
was uh most people were either getting
free over the airwaves or they were
paying for cable or satellite packages
so you get a ton of channels more than
you ever needed and you whatever you pay
for all them and they had to put
something on the air so they put reality
television but but today it's different
most people or at least half the people
are consuming through streaming networks
and streaming is a la carte so you pay
for this network if you like the shows
on that and if you don't like the shows
you'll watch that one and they have a
problem called churn meaning you just
finished watching stranger things on
Netflix you loved it but now you don't
want to pay for Netflix anymore so
you'll pay for this other streamer and
and you'll buy their their shows so it's
all about what shows they have so it's
not like Netflix can just go ahead and
put on some reality show because No
One's Gonna Pay 20 a month for that but
watch it if there's nothing else on if
they're already paying for it but
they're not going to sign up for it and
so that's the problem that the streamers
have now is something called churn and
that changes the landscape yeah for fun
let's talk about what's going on with
some of these big media companies it
seems like it's a really rough time for
them uh Disney just announced it lost a
bunch of Subs uh some of the weaker
streamers like peacock and even
Paramount plus with Paramount plus set a
ton of success with its Taylor Sheridan
Universe uh you know Yellowstone and
whatnot I don't have that and so I
frankly I feel a little bit like huh do
I have to subscribe to this thing just
to watch this Yellowstone
is that that one show you would you
would subscribe if you wanted to watch
it right yeah yeah totally so so a bunch
of the streamers are having a rough go
um even the most successful streamer of
them all on Netflix uh had it saw its
stock at a big haircut when it didn't
have robust growth numbers going for it
uh they started to clamp down I
literally got a call from someone who's
using my Netflix password
the other day saying hey it might be
time for me to get my own account
because apparently Netflix now is
clamping down on on that stuff and
Netflix is the success story in this
space but most analysts who look at this
space think there's like a finite number
of streamers that will be able to thrive
long term yeah there's probably more
than than there need to be uh the thing
is though I always say like that's a you
problem not a me problem so like when
times are good for the studios and they
make all these profits it's not like
they hand out bonus checks to the
writers you know they they keep those
profits and then when times are not as
good well that that's a you problem not
a me problem because I don't own I'm not
an owner of the network you know and I
it's funny because I've had um my wife
and I used to own a small business uh it
was it was girls apparel and we
manufactured in United States of America
which is an odd thing to do but we did
and so as a small business owner you
know we took care of our employees our
vendors our contact because you need
them our you know our contractors you
need them and so I wouldn't Pat if I had
a problem I'm not passing it off to them
this is my business I have to make it
work uh but it's different when you're
these multinational conglomerates They
don't serve they they serve their uh
their shareholders it's all about share
price and so they're going to do what's
best for their shareholders not
necessarily what's best for you know
even their employees I2 is a small
business owner uh I loved it it was good
times but you're right you make a bunch
of decisions and you don't cry in on a
river
what's going on that's not my problem
and like if I had to pay my employer I'm
not you know if I had a bad month it's
like I didn't tell my my uh my employees
or my contractors well sorry it's like
no that's me problem I have to figure
out how to make a good month
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by expressvpn
in a tough economy you're looking for
ways to save money and you know a sneaky
way you can do it expressvpn now you're
asking yourself how is that possible
doesn't expressvpn cost money it does
cost less than seven dollars a month but
it can help you unlock content that will
save you money for days and days what do
I mean for example let's say I'm a Duran
Duran fan which I am I want to watch the
concert movie of Duran Duran but it is
not available on Netflix in the US
however with expressvpn I can just beam
myself into the UK click on Netflix and
voila
Duran Duran and a bunch of other content
I could not have gotten any other way
it's a no-brainer if you want to
preserve your own data from the big tech
companies and get more content and save
money while you're at it go to
expressvpn.com Yang don't forget to use
my link so you can get three extra
months free that's exp r e s s vpn.com
Yang
expressvpn.com Yang to learn more
foreign
well as a numbers guy objectively even
if these studios are having a rough go
in terms of their stock price like that
they they can afford uh to compensate
Folks at higher levels I mean that
that's objective well some of their
executives are making a lot of money
yeah yeah I mean and some of these
companies now have had massive run-ups
even Netflix which is described I mean
you know they're still in the hundreds
of billions of dollars in terms of uh
values evaluation uh which uh you know
now it's a little bit lower than it was
you know like 18 months ago but
um but it's still plenty in the scheme
of things so who is on the other side of
this negotiation when you think of
Studios uh is it uh and how does that
negotiation work on their side
well so I'm not in those intuition
committees I just know what I what I
know from the outside but the studios
they band together under an umbrella
that they call the alliance of motion
picture and television producers the
amptp and so these are ordinarily
they're competitors any other time of
the year they're always trying to take
market share away from each other but
every three years they they band
together to negotiate as one because it
gives them strength uh and so that's
what we're negotiating against and was
it the case that one reason the writers
strike uh ended last time was like one
of the studios came forward and said
okay we'll cut this deal yes that's what
that's how you uh because you know the
guild were I think 9 000 writers so how
do you possibly stand up against these
multinational conglomerates like it's
they're so big and strong and we're just
a handful of writers and so the tactic
last time uh was that you really just
get them to turn against each other
because they're natural they're natural
competitors they're little Game of
Thrones action yeah they don't I don't
like they're not best friends and so
when you're when the strike is happening
they don't they can't make content
they're just sitting on their hands
watching their stock prices go through
the floor and they can claim they have a
different business model but no their
bot the business models manual is
producing and selling television shows
across the world and so the last strike
uh one of them stepped forward it was
United Artist I think was the first one
that stayed after like two or two months
of the strike they came to the writer
school and said okay let's let's Hammer
this out and make a deal an interim deal
and they proposed terms that were much
more favorable to the writers with the
condition that once the final deal was
settled that's the deal they would take
but then they had a competitive
advantage over the other Studios because
now they're back in the business of
making TV shows and and movies and so
that's how you do it you turn them
against each other
wow who's the weak link this time who's
the United Artist of 2023 yeah United
Artists and then maybe Letterman maybe
worldwide pants may have been first I
don't remember and then also Lionsgate
they were among the first two to uh you
know to drop it and then it's like
dominoes because now they have an
advantage over the others because you
know they want to make TV shows it is
like the herd man you got to pick the
weakest one yeah like the the one that
that really desperately wants
um to steal a march on the others uh
like I don't even say Lions game I mean
lionsgate's you know one of the less
well-capitalized Studios so just look up
the studios by market cap find the
lowest one and then everyone shows up
the door and be like hey we got a bunch
of writers here we go but you know at
the end of the day it's like
I I see where they're coming from I
don't hate them they're they're
prioritizing their job which is maximize
profits and they're not looking after me
that's not their job I don't expect them
to so the writers have to look after
ourselves and at the end of the day we
want we want the same thing that they
want which is they want to make
boatloads of money and we want to be the
people who make them that boatloads of
money right that's it we just want to be
able to afford to be able to do that
well that's a very positive perspective
let's say a human being uh were to want
to support you guys uh how can they do
so is there a way for uh everyday
Americans to say hey guys uh come to the
table pay the writers what they're worth
uh let's try and make this economy
actually uh you know work for folks you
know people ask me on social media
because I do Post every day on Instagram
and Tick Tock and Facebook and all that
uh they say like should we be should we
be boycotting the studios and right now
the guild is not calling for that uh our
goal is not to take down the studios you
know that we help build it's like we
want this is our business we wanted to
thrive uh we don't want to destroy it uh
we just want our fair share of it that's
all uh in terms of helping right now
what you can do uh you know is basically
if you see on social media a writer
talking about their experience that's it
just share it that's all it's free just
so you know uh public sentiment I think
counts for a lot and just share that
story uh we're not asking for money
other than from from our from our
consumers or viewers we just want you to
share our uh what's going on
so this does occur to me is there a
place someone could send a buck or two
if there is that like a fun to like help
writers make it through this time are
there Rich writers who are subsidizing
poor writers
yes there is and I'm afraid I don't even
know what what it is there is because I
don't I haven't looked too much into it
I do know if you could probably go to
the wga website and there might be some
links where you can contribute for for
writers right now though they say well
do you have a strike fund so writers are
not getting paid we don't have a fund in
terms of the guild is not paying us to
be on strike uh what they do have for us
is you could take a no interest loan if
you need it but then you have to pay it
back I believe it's something like 180
days once the strike is over so it's not
free money you got to pay it back uh
that's just for for the writers but if
you want to contribute I'm sure if you
go to WWJ website there's there must be
some links in terms of uh there are
funds that the writers have put together
for the other supporting Industries uh
you know uh grips and crew members and
stuff like that to help them get through
because of course they're suffering now
as well everyone in Hollywood is is
paying for this strike because
everyone's out of work that's a great
way to humanize it we're talking about
catering yeah catering Carpenters camera
people yeah even coffee shops near the
studios I mean they're hurting because
there's no customers now so everyone's
hurting yeah I mean again I think
putting a human face on this uh is
important and as someone who genuinely
thinks that having continued cultural
products is is important for our society
I mean heck even if you just want you
know stuff on your TV uh or on your
device you want the strike to get
resolved as quickly as they can yeah
absolutely everyone let's get back to
work let's get back to work that's a
great way to put it so if they want to
follow you Michael
um uh how can they best do so well I
post every day on Instagram Facebook
Tick Tock I'm Michael Jammin writer uh
yeah come follow me I post every day I
post anecdotes from what it's like to be
a screenwriter I had a break into the
business how to be a better writer how
to live a more creative life uh what
it's like you know stuff like that well
you were a very wholesome positive
person thank you
and I've learned a lot from your posts I
hope people have learned from this
conversation uh good luck to you and
yours man and I hope that that people do
decide to
um come to the table and get this thing
uh wrapped up because it's just not good
for anyone well I really appreciate you
for putting me on help amplify amplify
our voices because it really does help
so Andrew thank you so much for that
really dude if I were president
literally I'd be like guys no Hollywood
strike on my watch let's come to your
table and like bang this thing out
because I mean like who wants to
kill six months of uh I mean six months
I'm being like pessimistic there I mean
hopefully it's less than that but who
wants to kill X days of content
production where people could be working
living eating making magical stories
come to life instead for what like
because you know like because they're
gonna drag their feet making a deal that
we kind of know needs to be made at some
point anyway uh don't get me started
well no but you're right I mean like
last time you know before in 2008 right
before the strike it was the studio said
this is our best and final offer okay we
go on strike and then three months later
suddenly their best and final offer has
shifted so all that could have been
avoided if their best and final offer
came earlier all that could be avoided
you know what we need we need the
weakest Studio to step up
it'll happen it'll make the deal yeah
that's where you can do it let's find
that slow gazelle so that they could get
uh separated from the herd I am I'm
looking at you peacock
I don't know who it is I just insulted
peacock whatever thank you again Andrew
it really is a pleasure it's a pleasure
you know meeting you and and talking to
your audience so you too Michael
hopefully we have something to celebrate
before too long yeah thank you again
[Music]
foreign